so uh tell us a little bit about  yourself Jeff you know I really wasn't  always homeless  I had a house but it burnt down some  punk [ __ ] kids sparked the blaze that  burn everything I owned  teenagers a nuisance on society now I  just get drunk and then pray for death  that sweet [ __ ] release of death  that's what we want to pull the mask off  of homelessness we want to take you and  and put you on a pedestal and raise you  up for all the world to see so they say  oh no that's terrible we need to stop  that does that sound good to you my face  stores from when you punch me man and as  I said before I am sorry about that was  a misunderstanding but totally my fault  I lost 60% vision in my left eye a lot  of this stuff out there's a guy in our  shop she's smoking crack out of a light  bulb did he just die I don't know but he  needs to get his [ __ ] together it's not  like I punched alcoholism into him